bonsoir
donc vous êtes vous mesurer à m 90 un
peu moins un peu moi mais je pèse un peu
plus peser un peu plus sans qu'il honore
oui j'aimerais que vous aviez maigri oui
mais j'ai vraiment vous étiez à 104 me
dites pas que vous êtes toujours à 104
je suis monté au dessus
non si c'est les fatigue et puis c'est
les échecs électoraux avant ça fait
grossir les échecs électoraux comme les
soucis c'est que pour sabah on se
demandait pour ci va bouffer tous les
mardis avec michèle alliot marie à
l'elysée on connaît la teneur des
déjeuners de chirac il a envie de
prendre du poids réel aussi d'ailleurs
dans six mois c'est madeleine albright
elle a du poids politique mais elle a
une ligne que l'on suit ça c'est pas mal
trouvé pas mal trouvé c'est bien ça
commence fort alors cet ancien ministre
vous êtes maire du raincy vous êtes
conseiller régional ile-de-france
secrétaire national du apaire et comme
je lé directeur des affaires politiques
auprès de michèle alliot marie
donc là vous avez un souci en ce moment
c'est à dire que la date rang delanoë a
résumé la situation sur la mairie de
paris il a dit c'est plus des primaires
c'est un annuaire il ya ce lien là
peut-être oublié de dire quelque chose
oui c'est que lui les candidats tout
seul oui parce que pour éviter qu'ils
aient deux candidats on a offert le
ministère de l'éducation nationale jack
lang oui en fait chacun il y avait déjà
été à l'éducation nationale donc c'est
pas non plus une aberration dans les
années 80 il craque
il ya vingt ans et rex chirac peut pas
en faire autant d'aléas l'éducation
nationale de nommer des ministres en ce
moment alors les candidats ya tiberi qui
dérive
j'imagine quand même que le rpr essayer
de lui trouver du boulot ailleurs pour
qu'il s'en aille pourquoi vous n'arrivez
pas à le faire partir de là bâti berry
il a fait un mandat
les parisiens sont pas si mécontent que
saab ce mandat la difficulté c'est qu'il
ya eu des problème c'est qu'il ya eu des
affaires et c'est que même si c'est
injuste on n'est pas propriétaire d'un
mandat il revient pas à son parti mais à
l'électorat tu décidé il ya quatre
candidats aujourd'hui c'est pas nous qui
les avons suscité
mais bon si on disait il en faut un
on dirait c'est une caserne il
4 on dit c'est le bazar alors bon on va
essayer de régler ça se gâte résistant
je trouve tiberi parce que quand même il
a trois candidats face à lui il faut le
faire ils étaient résistants pour la
guerre des jeunes yahia se guérit j'ai
l'impression que tu coupes la tête et la
queue qui bouge encore il ya ce gain il
ya balladur et à françoise de panafieu
et ya tiberi ça fait 4 vous c'était chez
pas aujourd'hui mais jusque là c'était
plutôt françoise de panafieu votre
préférée non bah il ya des candidats de
poids
et puis il ya une candidate de charme
rétro le poids et le charme choisi ouais
mais michèle alliot marie va choisir
comment sérieusement parce que c'est pas
facile là entre bon françoise de
panafieu encore on peut y lire écouter
jean tickets les plus jeunes témoins oui
voilà c'est toi là mais entre se gagnent
en sérieux entre seguin et balladur
c'est celle de m terry pour michèle
alliot marie de choisir parce que c'est
quand même deux poids lourds se garer
balladur surtout se garder l avez dit on
va les mettre sur la ligne de départ on
voulait mettre dans les starting blocks
il et puis après on évite qui se
balancent des coups de pied dans les
tibias
c'est réussi on va leur proposer
d'exposer leurs projets mais ce que
michèle alliot marie dit c'est pas à moi
de trancher
on doit définir un profil avec les
parisiens
parce que c'est eux qui vont choisir
c'est pas les journalistes c'est pas
autre chose que de décider d'entendre
des élections surtout les gens qui ont
une carte du rpr à paris un jour vont
être appelés à voter pour choisir le
candidat ça sera pas tout à fait comme
ça parce que si on sait pas sic alors si
si on faisait ça on sera obligé de le
faire partout ailleurs puisqu'il ya
trente-six mille huit cent trente trois
communes en france et il y en a 36 1832
qui ont pas envie que ça se passe comme
ça mais qui va faire le choix parce que
là vous nous dites que c'est pas les
c'est pas les membres du rpr à paris qui
va choisir
il y aura les élus il y aura les
militants et puis il y aura aussi les
projets ils vont présenter chacun ce
qu'ils veulent faire pour paris j'ai pas
mal et de vos affaires mais ça ressemble
un peu à l'élection de miss france sur
tf1 la série on sait jamais on sait
jamais qui votent à dire si ses
distances
si ces miss france ça sera peut-être
miss paris ouais vous l'aimez un
panafieu aussi remarquer belges avaient
cru le comprendre mais bon pour autant
il ya tiberi ya balladur ya ce gain
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge regarde
devoir balladur en campagne oui non
parce qu'il est génial doux
ou en campagne sur les marchés quand il
tâte les melons avec ses gants aux yeux
quand ils descendent dans le métro parce
qu'à chaque campagne électorale balladur
descendre dans le métro pour faire un
peu pop la dernière fois était descendu
à la station louvre les gens ont cru
qu'une statue avait bougé j'applaudis
pas il paraît qu'il est il paraît qu'il
n'est pas paris il à chamonix ce week
end edouard balladur c'est vrai il a une
maison de campagne la marée c'est un
aubergiste qui l'a reconnu à varennes au
québec belles choses bien alors on va
parler un peu de vous eric raoult août
donc en 1972 1973
vous participez à un mouvement en faveur
d'un prof qui a été arrêté vous
manifester et vous apercevez que en fait
tout ce mouvement de protestation pour
soutenir ce prof arrêté a été en fait
manipuler par le par trou quatre profs
proches du parti communiste et là vous
vous dites je me suis fait blouser et
vous passer carrément de l'autre côté
c'est vrai il y avait des étudiants des
lycéens des profs qui disait il faut la
paix au vietnam
il disait il faut que la guerre s'arrête
et puis le jour où ils se sont aperçus
que il fallait que la guerre continue
ils ont oublié ce qu'ils avaient dit
auparavant et puis j'avais un pote dans
ma classe il était vietnamien et un jour
on l'a peu vu pendant trois jours on a
cru qu'il était malade il était chez lui
parce que sa famille avait été massacrée
à huer ce jour là je me suis dit il faut
choisir faut s'engager et je sais pas ce
que j'aurais fait si c'était un pote
communiste qui avait eu cinq mois j'ai
passé carrément d'un côté à droite mais
est ce que dit jean d'ormesson il dit
que le drame du 20e siècle a été d'être
obligé de choisir entre deux
totalitarismes
vous avez choisi les comités de soutien
au sud vietnam et donc vous êtes
retrouvé embarqué avec des gens de
droite voire d'extrême droite à ce
moment là j'étais pas coco ça m'embêtait
d'être facho je suis devenu gaulliste
c'est pas si mal parce que je suis resté
dans un engagement qui me permettait un
gaulliste quand même et gaullistes de
droite parce que plutôt munichois
oui c'était plus vous aurez aussi des
gaullistes de gauche capitan c'est un
gaulliste de gauche vous étiez plutôt
gaulliste de droite
oui c'était plutôt gaulliste
bien à droite que pour moi un bon bah on
n'a pas à avoir honte de ce que l'on
peut dire mais tout en respectant les
autres
vous disiez à l'époque que leur ainsi
donc la ville dont vous êtes le maire
aujourd'hui était le 51e état soviétique
c'était vraiment un fief des bonnes
choses là bas ma commune non le
département de la seine-saint-denis oui
puisqu'on est jumelée avec la corée du
nord est avec la banlieue de la havane
ah oui alors évidemment pour soutenir
pour partir en vacances en corée du nord
il n'y a pas beaucoup de volontaires
peut le faire et la banlieue de la
havane depuis de castro y est sa caisse
quand même des problèmes et je connais
vallier d'arrêt ce mot si oui alors donc
après bon ben voila vous vous rentrez en
politique de cette façon là vous devenez
un apparatchik du rpr voilà est alors en
85 délégué national à la jeunesse et la
tenez vous bien vous vous déclarez
jeunes tous bonne east alors j'aimerais
savoir parce que moi je vous y attends
les jeunes giscardiens tibet attend des
jeunes giscardiens bon encore jeremy
hunt ou bonus
qu'est ce que tout bon et l'idéologie
d'un jeune tout beau nist non ça fait
jamais dans un bolivien
qu'est-ce qui se passe
un délice et le chauffeur de sage
donc tu te demandes ce qu'un jeune tout
bon il avait été choisi par chirac pour
être secrétaire général du rpr et en
1982 1983
c'est lui qui réussit à garder la mairie
du 13e il succède à bernard pons et
c'est un peu le chef des jeunes
gaullistes bon hier il y avait marché il
ya robert hue
nous on avait eu poncet il ya eu tout
bon et puis ensuite il a été remplacé
par juppé c'est pas si si drôle que ce à
quoi tout bon il a été d'abord ministre
de la culture est ensuite ministre la
justice un cercle et moi je le préférais
à la culture plutôt que la justice parce
que la culture est lui en était sûrs
qu'ils étaient indépendants on continue
avec vous eric raoult et en 1988
oui vous envoyer une lettre à vos
électeurs potentiels et vous leur dites
nous et vous expliquer un vouloir dit
notre france à nous jeunes tous moniste
ce n'est pas celle de chiba où ce n'est
pas celle de françoise sagan ce n'est
pas celles d'harlem désir ce n'est pas
celle de krasucki c'est la france
immortel de jeanne d'arc de charles
martel de napoléon et de gaulle alors la
france n'est pas un ramassis de
socialistes qui font passer la défense
des étrangers des délinquants des
drogués avant l'amour de la france alors
moi je peux vous dire générer un comte
charles martel contre jeanne d'arc
contre de gaulle napoléon un peu plus
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on qu'il faut
dire que krasucki c'est pas la france
que françoise sagan c'est pas la france
c'est un peu des relents des années 30
avec l'anti france va écouter dans une
vie politique comme dans une vie tout
court on dit un certain nombre de
bêtises on fait des conneries là j'avoue
que le truc que j'ai écrit c'était
plutôt dans une campagne électorale et
ce papier là je le publierai pas dans
mes oeuvres choisies
ça vous choque ça samy naceri quand
vous entendez choses comme ça là les
maghrébins les blacks les italiens les
portugais les hindous ils font marcher
le business français il n'y a pas que
des dealers il n'y a pas que des voleurs
il ya des mecs qui se tape tous les
joueurs qui vont travailler et qui
ramène de l'argent et qu'ils sont là
mais je dis que à un moment donné il ya
eu un truc qui a couru comme quoi on
pouvait faire voter les étrangers et qui
que ceux qui avaient des papiers
étrangers au moins ils pourraient être
votées dans leurs circonscriptions dans
les mairies au raincy à nos gentils
c'est tout ça les municipales donc je
sais pas où ça en laisse mais ça sera
intéressant de que que tous ces gens là
qui font marcher le business qui se
lèvent le matin à 7h du mat et qui font
marcher les métros les bus qui ramasse
les poubelles tout ça puisse aussi voter
et pourquoi pas voter pour le président
de la république je sais pas on n'y est
pas encore arrivé en tous les cas nous
djamel bouras jamel debbouze tous ces
mecs là zidane on se bat on se bat pour
pour pour la france moi quand je vais
défendre un film je défends mon film
pour la france j'ai rencontré la
dernière fois d'aider des gens pour pour
taxi ont chanté la marseillaise pour
rigoler je suis français vous savez
durant les années 80 et 90 notre pays
n'était pas prêt et à chaque fois que
françois mitterrand relancer ses idées
ça faisait monter le pen alors le pen y
en a un coup sur la tête ne le réveillon
pas faisons en sorte qu' on puisse
promouvoir l'acquisition de la
nationalité française
calmement gentiment et puis qui a un
beau coup plus grand nombre de français
qui puissent voter et à ce moment là
comme ils ont la carte d'identité
ils ont le bulletin de vote bien
continue avec vous donc on continue
parce que s'ils voulaient moi je suis
pour la transparence oui donc j'ai rien
contre vous mais il ya des choses que
vous avez fait dans votre carrière je
suis obligé de vous parler dont vous
étiez par exemple ami avec roger
holeindre violence comme un dur du fn
votre supplément c'est pierre bernard
pierre bernard il a quand même été
condamné pour injure raciale bon vous
l'avez laissé tomber c'est vrai que le
jour où il est allé assister aux
obsèques du milicien paul touvier vous
l'avez laissé tomber ce bernard parent
faisait quand même eu des mauvaises
fréquentations ne sais pas vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure oui c'était
l'époque du vietnam tout ça et c'est
vrai que le vietnam
quand tout le monde a applaudi le jour
où les viet minh son entrée dans ses
gonds 75 ridicule on sait tous bons mais
vous ça c'était après quand même
l'époque où ces 88 89 vous fréquentiez
des gens comme pierre bernard comme
roger holeindre roger holeindre c'est
popeye c'est un ancien combattant marron
il a dit des bêtises et il a rejoint le
pen ce qui à mon avis est une preuve
qu'il n'a pas laissé tomber le fait
qu'il ya quand même un truc qui est
gênant chez le pen c'est que il peut
dire tout ce qu'il veut sur plein de
sujets quand il devient raciste
xénophobe et antisémite on peut pas
l'accepter
pour ce qui concerne pierre bernard mon
suppléant il est maire d'une ville
montfermeil et c'est dans ma
circonscription
quand pierre bernard disait qu dans
cette circonscription est dans sa ville
il y avait des difficultés avec une cité
qui s'appelle les bosquets où il ya
beaucoup d'insécurité c'était vrai et
quand il est allé aux obsèques de paul
touvier on a divorcé alors en 95 vous
devenez ministre de l'intégration du
gouvernement juppé alors là voilà vous
proposez là vous remettez en question le
rmi en disant que la culture et rémy
c'est la culture de l'inactivité
mais vous croyez pas quand même
sérieusement je veux dire c'est vrai
qu'à peut-être des gens qui touchent le
rmi et qu'ils foutent rien enfin
franchement quand on en est à toucher le
rmi on a commencé le minimum quoi
tirèrent 10 leçons si vous aviez été à
nantes a écouté le président de la
république
il a dit ça avec les mots d'un président
c'est à dire qu' il faut que les
titulaires du rmi fasse des efforts
d'insertion et ne reste pas dans je
dirais uniquement les trames de
l'exclusion
alors il ya le style raul tu es il ya le
propos présidentiel
moi j'ai voulu cogner pour réveiller
pour dire aux gens attendent et on peut
pas continuer
ça on avait inventé le rmi pour 190
mille personnes on en a bientôt neuf
cent mille ce que j'ai voulu dire c'est
que quand on a le rmi il faut aussi
essayer d'entrer dans une approche qui
vous permet de vous en sortir
et pas uniquement dans le public ce soir
en gros quand même c'est que vous avez
écrit cette fameuse lettre en 88 vous
avais tes copains avec bernard vous avez
dit ça sur les régimes et finalement
vous n'êtes pas si méchant que ça vous
l'apprécierez comme vous voudrez non
parce que vous demandiez aussi de le
déplacement des familles de délinquants
alors ça je comprends ça aussi bondi il
ya des familles dans certaines cités qui
vraiment les parents tiennent plus les
enfants ils foutent la merde il faut les
déplacer
enfin bon c'est quand même le doigt dans
un drôle d'engrenages sanon le cd portée
des gens g j'ai fait du chevelu mais ont
d'abord j'ai fait du chevénement avant
l'heure moi j'avais pas dit sauvageons
j'avais dit ça ce que je me suis aperçu
simplement c'est que bien souvent quand
on parle d'un problème il faut le vivre
et il faut essayer de le résoudre
quand on parle du problème des banlieues
en habitant dans le xvième où à neuilly
elle marche pas willy d'ailleurs il
n'habite pas à cintegabelle ou à l'hôtel
matignon on vous dit ça c'est pas faux
et en fonction de ça je peux vous
assurer que dans une cité tout le monde
se tient à carreau et qu'on peut pas
simplement faire des mesures pour ceux
qui pourrissent la vie des autres biens
alors quand vous étiez au gouvernement
toujours rêver inventer le plan vigie
casseurs d'ailleurs françois hollande
avait parlé de vous en disant que
c'était plutôt le plan vigie gaffeur
juppé lui il a fait le plan vigie
rondina prévu vous parlez d'intifada
concernant les banlieues quand même pas
exagérer non plus mais bon quand on a
parlé pardon mais de plan marshall le
plan marshall c'est un plan qui a été
assez le plan de l'aide américaine à la
france après la guerre à la deuxième
guerre mondiale c'étaient les banlieues
c'est pas l'intifida c'est pas les
banlieues sont pas détruites au point
d'avoir besoin d'un plan marshall faut
faire attention au pouvoir des mots non
thierry pour ce qui concerne les
événements faut s'en souvenir
les bagnoles qui brûlait des policiers
qui tirait il a fallu calmer tout ça et
si c'est pas moi qui ai parlé de plan
marshall
le plan marshall c'était mettre beaucoup
d'argent pour essayer de nous inscrire
mauvaise mais le nom plan marshall vous
rendez compte dans le plan marshall
c'était quelqu'un qui est pas
franchement rpr qui s'appelle adil
jazouli qui est maintenant les
conseillers de martine aubry qu'il
l'avait proposé je vais pas payer de
droits d'auteur bien alors ce qui s'est
passé pour finir ces quinze jours il ya
eu c'est ce qu'on appelait la sphère
tavernier de reconnaissez tavernier
célèbre réalisateur de cinéma
manifestent contre la loi debré vous
dites vous bien écouter venez habiter un
mois au quartier des grands péchés à
montreuil c'est ça et en fait lui il a
demandé à son fils
nils tavernier de faire un documentaire
qui s'appelle de l'autre côté du périph
et finalement à la sortie de quoi on
s'aperçoit c'est que ces gens-là ils
sont présentés comme des méchants en
fait ne sont que des malheureux
vous vous êtes catholique raul tu oui
vous ne comprenez ce que je veux dire
oui quand on est catholique
on va à la messe mais on s'est parfois
aussi se retrousser les manches pour
aider tout le monde mais pas simplement
pour fermer les yeux sur un certain
nombre de problèmes
là il s'agissait pas de montrer du doigt
certains on avait un problème de sans
papiers y avait pas d'un côté les sans
papiers de l'autre les sans pitié il ya
dans ce pays
un très grand nombre de personnes qui
sont en situation irrégulière si vous et
moi tiré on se retrouvait à new york
demain sans papiers on se ferait virer
un bébé je suis déjà fait virer mois
pour 2 grammes de shit donc oui ces tirs
manqués
s'il est une merde si on se retrouvait
dans une situation d'irrégularité
je crois que le mieux dans ce pays c'est
qu'on parle clairement on a une
population importante à intégrer et qui
s'intègre plutôt bien et qui fait des
réussites n'a lourdes ont pas n'alourdit
sont pas le bateau dans la mesure où au
bout du compte après on donne des
vitamines à l'extrême droite sans régler
les problèmes dans ce que vous dites là
c'est finalement vous êtes un homme de
bonne volonté
j'essaye d'être d'abord un homme de
volonté c'est à dire de vouloir faire
bouger un certain nombre de choses et
puis je me suis aperçu souvent que y'en
a marre de ceux qui parlent des
problèmes sans connaître moi les ogm ou
les problèmes agricoles je sais pas je
m'en étais or j'ai l'impression parfois
que bertrand tavernier
une fois qu'ils avaient filmé le mur au
péché c'est à dire un quartier difficile
de montreuil
il rentrait dans son hôtel particulier
son fils il a comme moi j'ai tourné avec
son fils dernièrement donc je connais
bien je connais pas le père mais je
connais bien le fils ils ont quand même
rester je crois qu'ils sont assez deux
trois mois au grand péché moi j'ai
grandi mon grand péché à côté j'ai
grandi j'ai grandi à la zup moins un
côté un peu plus bas avant donc moi je
connais bien je connais bien le beller
et je connais bien toutes ces sites est
là et je vous garantis que moi je suis
parti il n'y a pas longtemps j'étais
encore il ya trois jours avec des
copains à côté et quand je suis passé en
voiture parce que j'ai grandi là et
c'était ma société y a rien qui a changé
ils ont mis trois trucs des escaliers et
des machins pour les mots mon copain il
détient ma fille avait là la crèche là
et rien rien du tout les monges passant
aux attaques si génial la musique et
tout ils ont deux trois bus et des
machins s'est pas seulement de foot
début et aidé m 2 3 trucs machins faut
qu'il y ait un réel truc alors que ça
soit la droite la gauche je sais pas
mais qu'il ya une vraie volonté que
d'aider les mecs pour qu'il s'en sorte
parce qu'il n'ya pas que des il ya des
mecs qui font de la musique il ya des
mecs qui sortent et qui font du sport il
ya des vrais mecs qu'on la volonté mais
compaq ont pas encore fait le pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas été à l'école parce que
ils sont avec les potes à la sortie
devant les sites et à fumer du shit et
puis ils s'en foutent
mais s'il ya un vrai truc si un vrai
machin il ya moyen il n'y a pas que des
il n'y a pas que des cas là il n'y a pas
que dd
et des mecs qui vont faire des braquages
toute leur vie c'est parce que j'ai
voulu dire c'est pas ce qu'il a dit moi
j'habite donc 17e avant j'habitais à la
zup à côté de cela dure des grands
péchés on habitait à cette dent
aujourd'hui je les gagne et ça je me
suis tapé j'ai touché le rmi mois
pendant cinq ans je me levais le matin
je regardais les boulangeries j'avais
pas 5 francs pour m'acheter un pain au
chocolat
je me suis battu aujourd'hui je suis
acteur j'arrive à nourrir ma famille je
fais pas de politique je vais peut-être
entrer dans les trucs que je vais pas
contrôler mais j'espère que vous vous
ferez autant de choses même s'il se
plante et qui font des conneries c'est
vous les politiques c'est lui qui avait
annulé mais avant de faire cette
émission finalement si on retrace votre
carrière à ardisson l'a fait vous avez
donc dit beaucoup de conneries vous avez
eu une mauvaise fréquentation et vous
avez été souvent maladroit est ce que
pendant cette émission
faites votre mea culpa tout mea culpa
tout de suite comme ça on est tranquille
vous avez aussi dit des conneries
vous avez été maladroit est prévu une
mauvaise fréquentation j'ai essayé
d'être sincère parce que dans le passé
parfois je me suis fait fourrer et c'est
là c'est là que vous nous dites que se
faire fourrer c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
croit bon de terminer de tourner sans
nom il ya un truc avec vous la seule
chose qu'on peut dire c'est que il ya
quelqu'un qui a été naturalisé en quinze
jours en lui c'est évident les cheveux
monsieur mais qui sait c'est andreï
makine lui il a eu le prix goncourt et
le prix médicis la même année donc il a
été naturalisé par vos services en
quinze jours ça veut dire que pour être
naturalisé rapidement il faut avoir deux
prix littéraires dans la manette non non
c'est pas c'est pas ça je vais vous
expliquer comment ça s'est passé
il est allé sans papiers il est allé à
la préfecture il est allé à la
préfecture de paris
il a fait sa lettre il s'est exprimé et
le type qui était là lui a dit c'est
bizarre c'est trop bien écrit et
l'écriture est trop belle ça doit être
un faux ouais donc on a essayé de
récupérer ça le président de la
république avait été informé et j'ai
demandé à mes collaborateurs d'aller
plus vite mais les quinze jours
c'est ça qu'il faudrait avoir c'est à
dire que l'on puisse non pas attendre un
an deux ans ou trois ans pour obtenir la
naturalisation
parce que quand on a une origine
étrangère et qu'on veut choisir la
france faudrait que ça aille plus vite
bon bah merci en tous les cas de votre
franchise maintenant je vais vous faire
une interview
hull c'est pas fini je m'attends à tout
[Musique]
je m'attends à tout vient de dire eric
raoult ndt et vous ne saviez pas ce qui
allait vous arrivez vous êtes prêts oui
interview nul avant que des questions
qu'on compte si on répond ça ne fait que
voulais la justice et rien est ce que
vous préférez votre père ou votre mère
plutôt ma mère est ce que vous préférez
hitler ou staline ni l'un ni l'autre
alors si vous deviez vous réincarner
est-ce que vous incarnerez on arrête
laguiller simone veil
edith cresson ou marie france stirbois
plutôt simone veil plutôt simone veil
parce que c'est une sacrée bonne femme
ouais est ce que vous feriez si vous
étiez sur une île déserte
est ce que vous feriez plus facilement
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou un
mec très beaux ni babylon on me dit pas
ça rajoute j'ai trop loin - hitler
staline je veux bien encore on prend je
viens vous utilisez votre short et un
truc à 3 vous en sortirez pas comme ça
quand on est dans la politique bon on
peut discuter là on répond alors la nana
très laide avant une nana très laide
plutôt qu'un mec très beau ouais et a du
toupet des veaux non mais y avait dit
alors attendez en tout cas pas au public
non je suis pas comme ça quoi du tout du
tout non mais vous avez pas parce qu'on
a tous une partie masculin femina vous
pas du tout jamais jamais jamais essayé
j'ai jamais fumé j'ai jamais essayé je
mets fumée de nom mais par rapport à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'il ya des trucs qu'on fait ou des
trucs qu'on fait pareil
bon ben ça j'ai jamais fait bon ben donc
vous le savez si vous êtes tentés vous
pouvez écrire à la production de
l'émission qui transmettra surtout si
vous avez envie de vous taper eric
raoult très moche louer ni désert
ah oui ça c'est pour les gonzesses moche
c'est une bonne idée bien est-ce que
vous accorderez y ait plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites jeunes
où un jeune qui tapent sur des petites
vieilles c'est vraiment pour des
questions très confiant le jeune qui
tapent sur des petites vieilles c'est un
lâche 1 l'autre c'est un type qui se
trompe et qui veut pas vieillir
ouais donc vous avez plus chaque
enseigne hollande pour le vieux qui qui
qui sape des petites gens ouais parce
qu'il ya 44 ans je suis plus tout jeune
maintenant l'avenir c'est dur en même
temps 44 ans est rien il ya un ami qui
débarque chez vous à l'improviste
qu'est-ce qui vous feriez le plus honte
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de nuit
mein kampf ou un godemichet belge est
pas mein kampf et franchement j'ai pas
de godemichet non plus à bord mais j'ai
un bureau m'allonger la messe qui vous
feriez non c'est un jeu de l'esprit ce
qui me feriez on sait man quand vous le
godemiché le plus grand jeu minecraft
vous pourrez dire bon je suis pas nazi
mais je le lis pas ce qu'il faut l'avoir
lu il faut avoir tout lu donc c'est
vraiment une question piège kurita je
sais nager c'est d'avoir comment un
certain nombre de bouquins mais mein
kampf
j'ai vu dans une bibliothèque je les ai
pas lues et un godemichet il m'est
arrivé des fois d'en voir dans des
magazines mais j'en ai jamais acheter
y'a pas grand différence finalement
parce que dans les deux cas on l'a dans
le cul
donc vous avez jamais fumé de pétard
c'est que jamais tapé de garde sans vous
avez jamais utiliser de godemichés nom
faisait beaucoup de choses à apprendre
encore je vais vous dire notre éducation
et tester alors que nous on fait une
teuf après après y as
[Musique]
là
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter
tapie d' attentats puis sur un truc est
tous des clans riches et c'est simple et
efficace à ce extraordinaire c'est tout
le monde me demande pourquoi je suis pas
aller sur tf1 en vérité c'est pour pas
abandonner mon sampler bien alors eric
raoult et la bombe arrive dans 5 minutes
vous faites quoi
la bombe atomique c'est la fin du monde
fait quoi bon bah j'essaie de faire
l'amour une dernière fois un nom je
croyais qu'il allait répondre jeudi mein
kampf et musulmans à butare pardon à
catherine il ya catherine barba qui est
très déçue elle me dit dans l'oreillette
il fait l'amour en cinq minutes
alors est ce que vous seriez prêt va
souhaite un homme de bonne volonté à
échanger via le choix on vous dit voilà
si vous acceptez vous eric raoult et
d'être paralysé jusqu'à la fin de vos
jours
kadri friction ali il ya plus de famine
en ethiopie
j'ai actuellement un un pote qui est
paralysé ouais et j'essaierai plutôt de
me dire comment je pourrais faire pour
donner un organe pour le sauver c'est à
dire d'avoir une action pour quelqu'un
d'autre pour pas montrer que je suis
égoïste mecs eu au fond de moi-même
généreux pour quelqu'un que je connais
parce que ceux qui disent qu'ils
seraient prêts être pas je serais pour
des millions de gens qui connaissent pas
je suis pas sûr que c'est sincère
mais moi je sais quand j'ai écrit la
question je me suis posé la question
c'est quoi ta réponse
j'avoue franchement je le dis parce que
j'essaye d'être sincère c'est vrai
qu'être paralysé jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours c'est terrible le pire c est
paralysé en ethiopie bon alors on va
revenir à des choses un peu plus on est
tous les deux dans un chalet
ça y est c'est reparti et moi je meurs
et commence plutôt parler plus sortir du
chalet parce qu'elle la neige et une
tempête de neige c'était un jeu mais ne
faisait plus rien à manger
vous êtes obligé de me manger moi vous
commencez par quoi
qui a dit les fesses vous commencez par
quoi bon manger quoi en premier chez moi
je franchement moi je fête vous je
commencerai par les couilles parce que
d'autres les ont déjà goûté avant alors
vous avez de la chance d'avoir ma
dernière question
allez je vais dire la langue a comme ça
je pourrai plus parler non pas non je
suis mort et bien oui d'accord je suis
mort dernière question quel est l'animal
qui embrasse le mieux
je dis une chose c'est que josé bové a
trouvé la réponse à cette question
l'éléphant non le tapir non la femme
voilà on rallume la lumière
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu